hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from round 10 of the new in
chess classic melt weather champions
chester it's uh magnus carlson vs hikaru
nakamura and everyone was very much
interested will they again go for their
famous three-move draw with the double
bond cloud or will they
play an actual game this time uh and
well the result was very very satisfying
for everyone
now uh without further ado let's check
it out magnus with the white pieces
opens with e4 we have e5 by hikaru
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
c4 with bishop to c5 by hikaru
and here magnus went for the evans
gambit b4
uh of course that is uh you know not not
true but
almost true because he went c3 for the
main line of the joko piano
and after knight to f6 then he played b4
so
let's say a a delayed uh evans gambit
but not just yet first he played d3
and only after castles now he played b4
so there you have it b4 is on the board
uh we have bishop back to e7
and now knight b to d2 we have d5 this
has all been played before
nothing new here bishop to b3 and a6 now
and there is one game from the 2016
uh rapid grand prix russia uh from the
finals
daniel dubo defeated uh no uh daniel duo
drew a game against dmitry akovenko here
with castles here but here magnus goes
queen to c2
and it is now already as of move 9 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how hikaru deals with this
devious idea he plays h6 takes away the
g5 square
from white's pieces also creates some
more breeding room for the king maybe
later on in the game maybe ideas like
maybe knight
h7 to g5 are possible maybe you can push
f5
all depends on how white it develops so
here we have castles by magnus
and bishop to e6 just nicely continuing
development we have rook to e1 by magnus
and
rook to e8 uh bishop to b2 both
bishops are now nicely eyeing that black
king so if the position opens up that
could be
fireworks on the board we have bishop to
f8 uh opening up the e file for the rook
and also the bishop now will help out
with the defense a little bit if needed
we have
a4 magnus grabs more space on the queen
side and now
b5 by hikaru striking in the center you
do not want to allow white to push b5
and here just h3 all right also taking
away the
g4 square from black's pieces and here
hikaru trades in the center we have d
captures an e4 e a d captures on e4 and
now queen to d7 developing the queen
connecting rooks and asking what do you
do what do you want to play here so here
you could bring your rook into the game
you could maybe try shifting the knight
knight to f1 maybe to g3 or e3
but magnus decides to trade uh
everything of the board we have bishop
captures
queen captures pawn captures and b5 pawn
captures and
rook captures an a8 with rook captures
and now queen to d3 so here magnus says
okay i've traded uh some uh pieces and
some pawns over the board and now i'm
attacking your b5 pawn
so how can hikaru react to this well he
could defend it with rook to b8 which is
what he did
and the move does seem to be a bit more
passive than the
for example rook to a2 seems like a very
active idea
uh but as you'll see rook to b8 does
seem to be a superior move
uh because here for example if uh rogue
b1 you
you defend the bishop we are we're going
to play knight a7 defend our b5 pawn
and now uh black's position is fine but
the white can maybe play this freeing c4
move open up the dark square bishop and
now for example after characters
captures
we get this position and this is
perfectly fine for black but maybe it's
giving white a little too much so here
hikaru plays rook to b8 instead
seemingly more passive but as you'll see
that works quite better magnus plays
rook to a1
uh he prepares to bring another attacker
to the b5 pawn
and now knight the e7 uh and here
uh magnus did spend some time i think he
spent like four minutes uh uh uh
you know regarding this move and that's
a lot since you only have 15
uh from the start it this is rapid time
format and he played rook to a5 and here
already magnus was down to some four
minutes on the clock whereas hikaru had
nine and something
uh and um it's uh it's a very
interesting idea
uh because here hikaru does have a very
special move here
uh but i'm just gonna show you what
happens if you try c4 now c4 again
is possible here but then you just play
b captures and see four knight captures
and rook capture so black wins upon in
this line
uh but after rook to c1 you will
probably have no problem
uh you know fighting against the the
past c pawn but maybe you will i mean
it's rapid chess you do not want to play
something like that so magnus plays rook
to a5 and here he gives hikaru an option
for a very very
uh well sneaky idea so feel free to
pause the video and try to find
this idea for for hikaru while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
the move with the knight forward this
time it's not with the knight back and
for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's knight
the g6 and this is just a very nice
jump preparing knight to f4 with an
attack on the queen
and now the problem is you don't have
rook captures on b5 because if you do
this then knight to f4
attacks the queen and after the queen
moves you still have to keep an eye on
this rook
now we capture and after queen captures
now we play queen to a2
and this is very much a problem uh
because your bishop is under attack and
there's really no good way to defend it
if you play knight to c4
this just loses on the spot just queen
to b1 check
king to h2 and now queen to f1
threatening checkmate and
there really is no good way to prevent
this if knights the e3 defending
and attacking the queen then we just
pick up the queen on b5
so uh this uh would not be possible to
defend the bishop like this with knight
to c4
so you'd probably have to play something
like queen captures an e5 hope for a
trade here
bishop for a knight for bishop uh but
then
uh the problem is you get this knight to
d3 move attacking the queen and the
bishop and here
after the white queen moves wherever
we're just going to pick up this
bishop here be up a piece and have a
very very enjoyable game
uh white would be up two pawns but it's
maybe
maybe uh you know maybe it's plausible
who knows
but okay after rook day five of course
this is a rapid game you can't really
uh see everything or or maybe even go
for it maybe he did maybe he saw it and
maybe he decided okay it's not worth
you know even a piece for for two pawns
maybe
uh it's uh it's gonna be hard you know
not not a lot of time on the clock so he
just defended his b5 pawn with c6
and now bishop to c1 uh trying to
activate
this bishop somehow we have knight to c8
now preparing to shift the knight over
here
from there you're going to have a lot of
pressure there's going to be a double
attack on the e4 pawn also you're going
to defend the f5 square
which is very important and so at some
point white will
probably try and bring his knight to f5
so there's also that
so here we have knight to f1 magnus
continues with his plan and
now knight did uh knights to d6 like
like we mentioned uh we have knights to
g3 now
and here the problem is magnus only has
three minutes on the clock whereas
hikaru has some eight minutes and here
hikaru goes for queen to c4
uh going for a queen trade there were a
lot of possibilities here but
again he doesn't want a magnus to have
too much time to think and
this does make sense so here we have
captures captures
uh and now we have rook back to a1 the
rook is under attack and then now comes
c5
busting open on the queen side captures
captures and
now king to f1 the king must now come
into the game the queens are of the
board
we have knights to d6 now with a double
attack on this pawn here and now
knight the d2 defending and still uh
magnus needs to figure out how he's
going to get
this dark square bishop into the game so
here we have h5
trying to remove one of the defenders of
the e4 pawn and
uh magnus just defends it with f3 so now
the knight can move
hikaru still pushes h4 and now comes
knights to f5 the problem is after
knight the e2
seems like maybe it's playable uh this
knight really doesn't have a future
there
there is no square where this knight can
go to you could go like the g1 but i
mean
what's what's the night doing on g1 so
instead magnus goes forward after h4 he
goes
knight to f5 and here magnus was already
down to one minute and
some 25 seconds on the clock so here
hikaru captures we have captures
captures now doubling
across and spawns here and knight to d5
now going after the c3 pawn
so knight to e4 defending and attacking
the bishop here
and bishop to e3 now so offering a
trade-off of bishops here
and you can't really uh oblige here
because if captures captures with check
you're also going to lose the f5 pawn at
the end of this uh
well trade so instead we have bishop to
a3 now the bishop
does become a bit more active maybe
ideas like bishop here are possible with
a double attack but
rook to a8 immediately and now magnus
just goes back bishop to b2
and here hikaru grabs it rook captures
bishop captures
and now playing against carlson's
weirdly placed bishop
bishop to c1 now saying okay this bishop
is stuck here
i'm not allowing it to go to b2 you
cannot push c4 otherwise i just capture
and maybe i can get something like
knights to e3 in followed by knight to
c2 and then i just pick up the bishop if
possible
magnus of course not interested in
allowing that he plays king to e2
uh and now the the king can also help
out with the defense uh
there but now comes knight to f4 with
check and also by moving the bishop
you're also just threatening knight to
e3 check
and you know just picking up the f5 pawn
so here king e2 magnus uh
solves that and now knights the f4 check
now threatening the g2 pawn as well so
magnus needs to go back
knight back to d5 king to e2 we have
knight to f4 checking to g1
and here everyone thought that uh hikar
would just
will just repeat the position and he did
already go below one minute he was
down to some 40 seconds and then he
played f6 he said nope i'm just gonna
defend this pawn
try and bring my king into the game and
we are playing this my position is
better so why not
uh magnus quickly went knight to d6 he
goes after the b5 pawn
and now knight to d5 again hikaru wants
to deliver this check and pick up the f5
pawn
so king e2 not allowing this and if
you're thinking okay but why not give it
up why not just trade well you could do
that but then
after knight the e3 check uh you have to
go
uh here you cannot defend this pawn
because then the knight does come to c2
and you lose the bishop there's
that so you would have to play something
like king to e2
and then we can pick up the uh the g2
pawn and then you know who who knows
what's happening
so uh you know capturing on b5 not all
that great for black so instead we have
king to e2
and now again knight to f4 check king to
f1
knights to d5 king e2 magnus pretty much
you know
hoping for a draw there's nothing
nothing more for him there there's this
active knight but this bishop is just
just terrible and here hikaru goes
knight to c7 he defends the pawn and he
continues the fight now he's going to
try to bring the king into the game
maybe maybe he can do something and now
magnus just
pushes this c4 move upon he's been
waiting to do this
his entire game with b captures on c for
knight captures and now knight to d5 and
okay now the pawns are uh
no longer uh on the queen side only only
king side pawns are now
uh in the game and now we need to shift
our attention to the king side so here
knight to d6 uh and bishop to a3 now
attacking that knight here we have
knight to e4
and now comes knight to e7 again
attacking the f5 pawn
so f4 here and what do you play now we
have e
captures on f4 and king to f3 here
magnus says okay you can capture on f5
uh but uh then uh i think if if captures
an f5 magnus was not uh
probably not gonna go with king captures
on f4
maybe he was even considering knight
captures on f6 check because this is
pretty much a force to draw
uh because after captures and captures
you're also going to capture this guy
push away this guy
capture this guy for example king f7
bishop g5 king g6 we're going to capture
on f4
and now with king h4 just g4 check and
now you kind of have to
uh you have to capture otherwise you
know uh we just win the night here so
captures
and now after bishop captures there's no
no winning winning this position maybe
if it was a blizz game you know with no
time increment then maybe you could you
know
try and uh flag white but uh you know
with increment
you don't go for this so hikaru still uh
keeps his options open he plays bishop
to c1
and now king to g4 by magnus we have
knight to d5
uh and now bishop to d4 so
yeah waiting to see what what hikaru
will do we have bishop to e3
now offering a trade here and while you
could capture this
for example bishop captures an e3 then f
captures and then this pawn is kind of
kind of strong
so instead we have knight the c3 now
offering a trade here if you go for
uh sorry uh offering the trade here
after bishop to e3
if you go for the bishop captures an e3
then just have captures like we
mentioned so instead we have knight to
c3
and now comes knife the e7 declining
this because if you go for bishop
captures knight captures then
uh you know uh white white will be a
little bit better here
but uh he he doesn't enjoy that so
instead we have
knight back to e7 uh and now comes
knight to e2 and here uh players were
kind of low on the clock but not that
much i think he car was still below one
minute magnus somewhere
around the two-minute mark and here as
none of the
players could make any progress they
just repeated knight to d5
we have knight to c3 knight back to e7
knight to e2 knights to d5 and the
knight
to c3 and he was in this position on 57
that the players agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more more to be done
here
uh so really really a tough game is a
tough game especially for magnus as you
can see he's been struggling the entire
game and
uh the there really weren't no uh
moments where he could have gone for
something better
whereas there were a lot of moments
where hikaru probably could have gone
for something better like that maybe a
slight improvement with the knight the
g6 idea
uh that we mentioned but if you're
wondering where magnus
really went wrong in this game because
he did have the white pieces
uh it was uh in fact in this position
right in the beginning where he didn't
go for the evans gambit
so uh he didn't go for the evans gambit
and then he suffered for the rest of the
game
don't uh you know don't let this happen
to you in your own games
uh but yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it really a nice
nice uh long struggle uh i would like to
thank matthew benoit uh happy birthday
brad rice
raffle karanath tiberio and rahul
karanath
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament tomorrow checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank you i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day